you're watching flight coming up the
science of winning what it takes to be
the best on the rugby pitch extreme 360
we meet the climbers using advanced
cameras serving up controversy why these
guys have come in for criticism and it's
time to plan your escape in this week's
games review hello and welcome to swipe
this week we're taking a look at the
technology making the difference between
victory and defeat in rugby we're here
in Guildford where Harlequins drop a
union team trained and where every
players movement is carefully recorded
and analyzed so what does it take to
create the perfect performance on the
pitch we'll sergeants been finding out
it looks a bit like a remote control or
a mobile phone but information gathered
by this little box could hold the key to
success on the rugby pitch sports
scientist the GPS tracker sits in a
small pocket at the back of the shirt
and together with a heart rate monitor
allows the team of analysts to record
every move the players make
this year we've got a system with
Deloitte that has pretty much everything
going into its all of our heart rate
measures any monitoring measures the
wellness questionnaires the voice
without RP ease of sessions the GPS data
the physiotherapy data everything kind
of gets pulled into one place which
allows us to kind of analyze and look
for trends and try and best manage the
squad and best manage the load the GPS
isn't the only tool available to the
team another analyst positions himself
on a nearby rooftop to film the session
and above the players heads a drone
keeps tabs on training the footage
captured by the cameras is then fed into
a computer and analyzed in detail for
the coaches this technology is vital to
understanding the stresses on the
players certainly I think all clubs are
right you know at the cutting edge of
what of how you interpret data and
that's the biggest thing for us is it's
not just having reams and reams of data
it's actually sifting through it all and
having the people here who'll actually
be able to provide us with the data that
matters and that's a huge part of what
we do just like any Premiership team
competition for starting places the
Harlequins is tough and many of the
players work with the analysts to
improve their game and prepare for
matches it's great to get get an
overhead view you can see running lines
you can see how things go and then we
get it sent a copy of training so when
you get home you're able to then log in
have a look through the video and see
how you're doing because it's one thing
feeling it when you're on the pitch you
might not necessarily be able to see
everything around you when it's on a on
a on a video clip you can then get all
this goers here maybe I should have made
a different decision winning a rugby
match is ultimately down to who scores
the most points on the pitch but the
careful analysis of data could give you
a head start well before you even
kickoff will Sargent Sky News well I'm
joined now by Kevin Gill the senior
performance
Harlequins Kevin some of that techniques
are in Wills piece there is truly
fascinating there's all of it make your
job easier or does any of it add an
extra layer of pressure so a lot of the
tech is about making our job easier
that's why we've got it but some of our
obviously new technology we've got to
learn how to use it so in terms of the
drone learn how to fly it
learn the kind of footage we're gonna
get and then how to get that into a
format quite complicated it can be quite
complicated yet to get it into a format
that works for all our coaches and all
our players so there's a slight
difficulty with that button essentially
yeah it's about looking at new
technology and try and stay to stay
ahead of the game all the other club
also have a similar amount and level of
technology
well not quite I mean as a department
we're constantly evolving so we're
trying to keep our finger on the pulse
and stay ahead of the game so each club
is doing the same so as as I say it's a
bit of a cliche if we're not moving
forward we're moving backwards so
hopefully if we're looking at new
technology new things out there we're
trying to stay ahead of the other clubs
and what about across sports in general
where does rugby rank in terms of how
advanced their technology yep
right up there yeah I'm actually part of
the English Institute of Sport and which
is the leading provider of sports
science practitioners across the UK so
I've seen British Cycling I've seen
canoe slalom end lots of different
sports so it's great for us to be able
to tap into that and bring that into
rugby but yeah my opinion is that rugby
is right up there in terms of the
technology we use so you mentioned
cycling there has rugby been influenced
by the kind of technology you see in
cycling well bits and pieces that I've
learned from cycling I've brought in
here and then back the other way as well
things that they would did here before I
before I came here I've transferred back
to British Cycling as well what about
football where would football rank
I'd say football I was at Liverpool
Football Club a while ago at the academy
and I'd say that
rugby's ahead of the game
yeah in terms of analysis we use here
all right well Kevin Gill thanks for
joining us shorty and now for something
different
we've all seen pictures of climbers
scaling mountains they make it look so
easy that's probably because it's hard
for us to fully understand how hard
their task is well now one team has come
up with some specially advanced cameras
to get us that bit closer to the action
Danny Burton of itch reports for those
with a fear of heights here's a chance
to see the world from a mountain
climbers perspective without danger or
risk to life along with their normal cat
extreme climbers Stefan Siegrist and
reigning speed record holder Daniel
Arnold carried specially developed
photography gear as they tackled the
North Face of the Eiger mountain in the
Swiss Alps in their packs a box
containing six cameras a rig which could
shoot full circle rechargeable batteries
a GPS unit and telescopic arm the
equipment designed not to hinder for
this project we recorded 360-degree
stills and videos with multiple cameras
and after that in post-processing these
images are then stitched together into a
seamless 360 image the end result images
that effectively act like Google Street
View capturing a range of angles to give
the online viewer an interactive
experience the video too is quite
spectacular the climbers please they can
now share what they see with the rest of
the world the mountain is a I find it
very aesthetic it's a big face it has
different difficulties in eyes and drops
definitely a nice very nice climb and
some great at range you can have they
may be used to the scenery but even the
climates were amazed by the results it's
hope this venture will inspire others to
consider the extreme sport or at the
very least appreciate the effort
involved Danny Burton ovitch Sky News
you're watching SWA nights coming up we
take control of an unusual snake in our
games review but first here's a roundup
of anything you might have missed this
week Microsoft's former chief executive
Steve Ballmer is stepping down from the
firm's board he's been with a software
giant for 34 years and says he wants to
devote more time to the Los Angeles
Clippers basketball team which he
recently bought but he won't be selling
his Microsoft stock it's worth around
nine billion pounds having a robot
Butler sounds pretty good but a US hotel
chains been criticized for trying to
introduce them
Starwood wants to install the droids in
a hundred hotels across the world but
the UK hotel workers union says they're
no replacement for top quality customer
service the machines are designed to
deliver things like toothbrushes and
towels to guests rooms the late actor
Robin Williams could have a character
named after him in the next Legend of
Zelda game more than a hundred thousand
people have signed a petition calling
for Nintendo to honor the comedian who
appeared in many of their adverts
Williams even named his daughter Zelda
after the game the star was found dead
last week at his home near San Francisco
after committing suicide an app created
by the actor Tom Hanks that lets you
type on an iPad a bit like a typewriter
has gone to the top of the iTunes chart
Hanks writer looks old-fashioned but
unlike its ink filled for father it can
send emails and shared documents the
captain Phillip Starr said the app was
inspired by his personal collection of
antique typewriters 8 out of 10 18 year
olds think it's too easy for young
people to see pornography online
according to a survey for the Institute
for Public Policy Research viewing
pornography becomes typical as early as
13 46 percent of those surveyed said
sending sexual or naked photos or videos
is part of everyday life for teenagers
and you watch for children that uses GPS
to help their parents keep track of them
is coming to the UK in December if the
child gets lost they press a panic
button on the hero watch and their
location is sent to a family members
phone
it also lets parents create virtual
boundaries and sends them a notification
if there
leaves that area the British video games
industry was given a boost this week as
tax relief finally kicked in the perk
will only apply to companies making what
the Treasury calls culturally British
games so if the game is made in the UK
and it's providing British jobs the
developer should qualify around five
hundred game studios are based in the UK
employing around nine thousand people
now you might have to get a little bit
imaginative for this week's games review
we've got battles with aliens and
playing God in your own fantasy world
they're all a little bit quirky
is Holly Nielson to explain more anyone
can be a god so long as someone believes
in them goddess is Peter Moniz first
steps into a scenery changing mobile
game it's also free-to-play which is new
from as well it's an interesting concept
so you take the role of God and you
nurture the civilization not just by
creating buildings but also by shaping
the land around you it's a fabulous idea
sometimes the controls were saved in the
world can be a bit fiddly and not really
work on the touchscreen the AI also has
a bit of an issue the villagers tend to
wander around in very odd ways which
doesn't really help it does have a great
aspect where if you sail to another
Island it involves a kind of puzzle
element to shaping the land kind of
getting your villagers in one place to
another it's not a game that you can sit
and play for hours it's very much a dip
in and out of kind of game but if you
treat it is that it does open up very
slowly but it does become a satisfying
play someone is about to steal the
kingdom stone and I have the
freedom planet is a real love letter to
the old 16-bit Sega games everything
from the humanoid animals to the
fast-paced platforming even the way the
characters die is all in homage to the
old 2d Sonic the Hedgehog games it has a
massive replayability factor with fact
you can play for the modes and three
different characters there's a classic
mode and adventure mode time trials and
collectibles one thing that is different
from Sonic the Hedgehog is the way that
you destroy the enemies it's not like
the Hedgehog you know you jump on them
and it keeps the pace moving well and
this you have a deliberate attack it
slows the pacing down a little bit
however I think it works because it
makes you explore and look around at the
world that they've created as well as
having incredibly fun gameplay I think
what they've done with the 16-bit
graphics is really inventive it hasn't
just recreated the old Sega games but
it's actually turned them into what you
wanted them to be as a child they've
created a much more detailed world and I
think it just looks fantastic
in her whole commute that glides through
the air in your task is go through 17
different areas and find a way of
freeing your other snake friends it's a
bit of a confusing game but it looks
absolutely incredible the gorgeous kind
of psychedelic colors with the alien
like flora and fauna the way that you
interact with the environment is
incredibly creative as always with games
like this it's strong points are also a
little bit of a negative it can be very
confusing because it doesn't have any of
the clutter of a usual game there's no
Maps there's no counting it doesn't tell
you what you've done although it makes
the game look great it means that you do
often find yourself lost in the war in
like endless areas that there seem to be
however I do really enjoy the fact that
it doesn't take you for a tutorial
kicking and screaming and just lets you
explore and find the world in your own
way this gave vs. a sandbox game in
which you plays a prisoner and your role
is to break out the prison now it's a
time management game so you've got to
try and find a way of breaking out of
the prison while sticking to the strict
schedule you don't want to draw
attention to yourself by not turning up
for roll call but you've also got to
figure a way out and it's really clever
in the way that there are so many ways
you can break out the prison you can do
a classic great escape you can dig a
hole or you can disguise yourself as a
prison officer or cause a rise and try
and sneak out it's really amazing how
much they've managed to fit into this
little game the classic 8-bit graphics
look fantastic although the controls can
be a bit fiddly it's a little bit
difficult to master them and it takes a
little bit of time to learn that as I
did the dimmer screen punching someone
and talking to someone is in the
spacebar so remember that
despite the fiddly controls it's very
addictive and I think there's hours of
gameplay to be had in this game well
that's it for this week and don't forget
you can catch up with all the way it's
breaking tech stories on sky near iPad a
smartphone apps and sky nice calm see
you again next time bye bye